he's one of the most fearless and
fascinating thinkers on the planet
provocative polemicist best-selling
author World leading scientist Richard
Dawkins one on one
[Music]
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening London welcome
to a special edition of Piers Morgan
uncensored I'll go head to head tonight
with one of the most influential
intellectuals there is
he's one of the most controversial
thinkers on the planet biologists
controversialist world famous atheist
Richard Dawkins inspired Millions by
popularizing evolutionary biology but is
his work on religion and morality it's
become a lightning rod for controversy I
despise uh people who believe something
without evidence and then go out and
take action which damages other people
his 2006 Blockbuster The God Delusion
made in the global face of atheism
what's wrong with in your opinion with
believing in a god regardless of who the
God is I think it's false uh I think
that it's a matter of belief without
evidence while his combative style has
created fervent admirers and ferocious
enemies
to his fans he's the whip smart
scientist who's Waging War for facts
over feelings
science is interesting and if you don't
agree you can talk to his critics he's
incendiary out of touch and deliberately
offensive well tonight he's here and
he's uncensored
and Richard Dawkins joins me now Richard
Dawkins thank you very much indeed for
agreeing to appear on Piers Morgan
uncensored pleasure I assume you will be
uncensored of course you've never been
said so have you no
try to sensei and we're going to come to
a bit of that letter of this canceled
culture has even come to your door what
do you make of of that people these days
not wanting to hear opinions they don't
like I think it's very sad I think
especially in universities where I spent
all my life universities are places
where you should be free to speak your
mind and listen even to something that
you don't like and it's very tragic that
universities seem to have bought into
the idea that if you don't like what you
think you're going to hear from someone
you should shut them up and refuse to
let them speak yeah I mean I find it
completely baffling that at a place of
Education where the whole point is to
test your own thought processes and to
deliberately be exposed to other
thoughts we're now in a place where a
lot of students feel they just don't
want to hear it they only want to hear
stuff that validates their own opinion
they use this word safe they want to
feel safe and university is the one
place where you should not feel safe yes
dangerously safe yes exactly in terms of
thinking yes you know I just think you
want to be
constantly challenged and provoked about
what you believe and what you think you
ought to be physically safe but but yes
intellectually you should be challenged
I'm going to come more to this because I
think the whole canceled culture woke
kind of world we live in is is a
fascinatingly disturbing one and you've
got strong views of it but I want to
start because you're known as one of the
world's big thinkers I want to start
with some big theme stuff and I guess
there's no bigger theme than
Evolution itself
and I think I'd ask a question like this
what do we know now about where we've
come from and what don't we know okay we
know once you've got a self-replicating
entity which nowadays is DNA but it
wasn't originally want to see what life
started once natural selection darwinian
natural selection has got going then we
pretty much understand
the four billion year history of what's
given rise to us and all other living
creatures we don't know how it started
and that's still a mystery and it may
always be a mystery because it happened
a very long time ago and we may never
know exactly what did happen we know the
kind of thing it had to be what kind of
thing do you think it was it was the
origin of a self-replicating molecule a
molecule that makes copies of itself
DNA is such a molecule but the original
one was almost certainly not DNA because
DNA is a it's been called a high-tech
replicator there had to be a precursor
to DNA
something the laws of chemistry gave
rise to a molecule which had this
unusual property of making copies of
itself
which mutated
changed in random ways and that gave
rise to competition between rival
versions of it and that gave rise to the
whole panoply of Life eventually okay so
I
Catholic I was raised to Catholic
um so I'm a religious person which I
know is anathema to you we'll come to
that but my arguments with atheists
historically have always come down to
one thing and maybe you've got an answer
which will persuade me of the Folly of
my ways which is this
what was there at the start
we don't know
but I don't know and you don't know but
no human brain unless you want to
correct me
can actually comprehend nothingness
right no but it's a it's a fallacy to
think that because I don't understand
how it happened therefore God did it I
mean that's just weak well no I'm not
okay but I'm prepared to have an open
mind about this yes but somebody did and
I just I've never met a human brain they
can explain to me
what happened before say you go for the
Big Bang argument what was that before
what does nothing look like physicists
are debasing this I'm not a physicist
but they're debating it my point is that
they don't know and I don't know and you
don't know and it doesn't help to
postulate a God that did it you're
certain is not a God and yet you admit
you don't know no I'm I'm certain that
it doesn't help to postulate something
very complicated at the outset because
what we've got is primeval Simplicity
and from that stems everything and what
science does it starts with Simplicity
which is relatively easy to understand
and from that it develops into the whole
of the universe and the whole of life it
doesn't help to start with complexity
and a creator has to be complex the
reason that I subscribe to the theory
there must be a more powerful being out
there than anything the human race has
created is because like I say a human
brain can't comprehend nothingness or
what may have come before nothingness we
can't we're not able to extrapolate what
that is right I mean no scientists can
explain nothingness can they plausibly
well maybe they can't you'd have to talk
to a physicist but even could you
explain it no I'm not a physicist but
either you're a very smart guy and
you're a very vehement atheist
well you're pretty vehement I mean you
just think all belief in all gods is
ludicrous right I think that it doesn't
help to introduce complexity at the
outset that's my No I get that but but I
don't think you do get it well no I do
because I but you're asking me to
consider that my own belief in a deity
that may be above human thinking and
understanding and brain power that was
there
universally that my theory is
scientifically flawed whereas I would
throw back at you okay but I need to be
given an alternative I need some
scientists somewhere to explain to me
right four four billion years all right
but then what was there before that well
scientists can't answer that and they
and what they say is things like it's
like going to the it's like going north
of the North Pole I'm sure I gather
recently introduced Stephen Hawking he
probably said that to you yeah he did
actually yeah
um but the point is this science can
explain things starting with Simplicity
and working up too complexity I get
there but where science can't explain
something
I.E in the case I just gave you is it
not possible that you're all wrong on
the atheist side of the argument it
could be it could be all wrong but what
when you might get a shocking surprise
one day when you're no longer with us
you might and you discover we were right
all along it's possible you can see it
as possible it's highly unlikely you
don't know though do you of course I
don't
um
scientists take a pride in admitting
when what they don't know and they don't
know what happened before the Big Bang
they don't even admit that the word
before means anything with respect to
the Big Bang Jesus will tell you but it
has to I mean well it doesn't because
that's a naive statement
um physicists will say that that you do
not have to say there was a time began
in the Big Bang is what some physicists
will say to which I immediately respond
with my basic human brain well okay if
time began when did it begin what was
there before right which is a fairly
obvious question it is a very obvious
question it's too obvious and physicists
will tell you they'll be naive yeah but
they don't know why I'm being naive
because they can't provide have you ever
just said the human brain is not capable
of growth right that's my point so why
is it not possible that there is a
superior being power which many people
believe in different ways at the bottom
of the garden and all sorts of things
are possible you can't deny that well I
said I've never seen fairies in
regardless you've never seen God either
no but you don't know for sure that
either doesn't exist no I don't know
that fairies don't exist fairies May
well there may be leprechauns
it's milder about this as you've got
older yes have you got more accepting
that there may be you may be wrong less
certain well
um yes of course a scientist may always
be wrong and that's a definitely a thing
that a scientist has to say but I'm not
vehement you're provoking me to be
vehement because you're taking that tone
with me well you've been provoked before
yes and you've been quite vehement in
response I'm actually not trying to
provoke you I'm genuinely curious yes
because I don't have all the answers but
I'm always skeptical of people who think
they do I don't think you think you do
absolutely not but you're a mission that
you don't have all the answers to me is
quite interesting because it lends the
possibility you might be wrong well it's
not interesting I mean no no scientist
has all the answers
um but but the one thing you shouldn't
say is that because I don't know
therefore God did it that's that's what
I think it happens when you die
as Bertrand Russell said I believe that
when I die I shall rot and nothing of my
ego shall remain that's it
yes yes nothing there's nothing else how
could it how could it be otherwise I
mean you you have a brain an evolved
brain which works by nerve impulses and
when that decays what could possibly be
left so you don't believe in for example
a spirit or a soul none of that is
that's all conditional entirely on a
link to a an actual cerebral yes if by
spiritual Soul you mean something that
outlasts the brain that I do not believe
in it no really
well how could I well people have gone
through weird sort of outer body
near-death experiences where they
they've been pronounced dead for a few
minutes they always talk about almost
all of talk about this weird there's a
tunnel a tunnel right at the end yeah so
I mean yeah it could be couldn't it yes
well read Susan Blackmore on that would
you like to be pleasantly surprised or
would you be appalled if you were wrong
uh well I would be pleasantly surprised
for a while I don't think I'd like to
deliver all eternity would you would
again I don't know it depends what it's
like well fraternity was watching you
know Cricket at Lords all day and
watching Arsenal win every weekend yes
give me that really well if eternity is
is blissful and a wonderful experience
and some people believe I think there is
something actually rather frightening
about eternity and I'd be quite glad to
be spending it under a general
anesthetic
feared given the finality of what you
think death to be do you fear it as you
get older I fear the process of dying
but when you're dead you don't know
anything it's just like before you were
born
I think it was Mark Twain said I was I
was dead for billions of years before I
was born and never suffered the smallest
inconvenience
but when when you have loved ones who've
died for example that's tragic yeah but
how do as somebody who believes
literally in the finality the the
rotting of the body and that's it it
must be worse than for somebody like me
where I genuinely believe there's
something better to come it's it's worse
so what
not so what just curious that it must be
for you awful each time far worse than
it is for people who ever believe yes it
is a lot of people take great comfort
from their belief in God that there is a
different life out there yes they do you
don't have that sucker at all no
so is it incredibly painful more more
for you perhaps than something that I
don't think who is a Believer let me put
it to this way if you really did believe
it wouldn't you say to the person on the
deathbed looking forward to seeing you
in purgatory a lot of people say looking
forward to seeing you in another life
yeah yes a lot of people say that you
don't really believe it though actually
I I do yeah I do actually because I find
it when I think about it in Big Picture
which is your great thing
thank you How likely is it that we just
got put on this planet Earth as human
beings as a one-off kind of entity that
existed here and then you die and that's
it and we and it only lasted four
billion years and before that was
absolutely nothing at all How likely is
that to have been the case I don't think
that's likely my human brain which is
limited does not think that is likely I
think it's very likely really it's
exactly what happened yes we are a tiny
tiny dot in the universe exactly so you
don't know what else is out there really
other than what scientists have already
established no I I think it's highly
likely that there are other beings out
there which are much cleverer than we
are
um super human not Supernatural but
superhuman and I would love to meet them
I probably couldn't understand what they
said
about but whether
where we are right now which I think we
can reach
them here about the
culture wokery and what it's doing to us
as human beings about Richard Dawkins
after the break
[Music]
what about with Richard Dawkins Richard
recently members of the ecology and
evolutionary biology language project
funded by scientists in the US and
Canada produced a list of 24 harmful
terms these included male female man
woman mother and father they're
recommended using phrases like sperm
producing egg producing XY XX individual
and they should be used to avoid
reinforcing societally imposed ideas of
a sex binary to which your response was
the only possible response is
contemptuous ridicule yes which I
cheered I have to say because it was
complete Madness
how have we come to this
English is my native language it's your
native language and um I propose to use
it in the way that I have always used it
and I'm not going to be censored by
have you looked at those people I mean
they look like teenagers well it's just
strongly to me is they they want to
what they call degender and neutralize
language but they're doing it from a
completely false pretext you can somehow
pretend biology doesn't exist
particularly when it comes to someone's
sex I mean it's incontrovertible there's
no scientific doubt about this and yet a
small group of people have been quite
successful actually in reshaping vast
ways of the way Society talks and is
allowed to talk it's bullying and we've
seen the way
um JK Rowling has been bullied catering
stock has been bullied
um they've stood up to it but but it's
very upsetting the way this tiny
minority of people has managed to
capture the discourse um to
um really talk aren't nonsense
what's the answer to it
science I mean um
there are two Sexes
um you can talk about gender if you wish
and that's a subjective when people say
there are a hundred genders for example
yeah I'm not interested in that as a
biologist there are two Sexes uh and
that's all there is to it you had a
humanist award stripped in 2021 because
of your comments about this kind of
thing uh you had a tweet in April that
year in 2015 you tweeted Rachel dolezal
a white chapter president in America the
na NAACP was vilified for identifying as
black
she was white some men choose to
identify as women some women choose to
identify as men you'll be vilified If
you deny that they are literally are
what they identify as
discuss and all hell broke loose and you
had your award stripped because you were
effectively doing what JK Rowling others
have said you were just espousing a
biological fact I wasn't even doing that
I was asking asking people to discuss
discuss that's what I've done all my
life in universities why have we lost
that ability to actually have an open
and Frank debate there are people for
whom the word discuss doesn't mean
discuss it means you've taken a position
um which I hadn't
um but anyway
um I thought it was a reasonable thing
to discuss this was on on the one hand
uh I actually wrote a couple of
follow-up articles to it to this
um
race is actually a much more fluid
concept than than sex
um for one thing many people are of
mixed race and so they really can be
um you know right I had my DNA done for
example yes uh properly tested it came
back I had zero English DNA zero I
actually have six percent Middle Eastern
yes for example right so that was a
shock to me I had no idea yes um a lot
of killed a lot of Irish and Scottish
and Welsh yes but no English whatsoever
yes well we're all mixed and therefore
it actually is a perfectly reasonable
thing for somebody to identify as some
particular race if they want to but sex
is not like that sex really is binary
and therefore
um it's it's something it's certainly
worth discussing that odd anomaly which
I pointed out in that tweet I mean we
now have a situation where in women's
sport for example transgender athletes
are destroying women's records
and beating women in women's sport you
know by immeasurable distance we don't
disagree about this there's no no but
we're doing right yeah
um I mean it seems to me complete
Madness just scientific Madness that
we're allowing this to happen it is one
of the problems that scientists have and
we saw this in the covid pandemic is
that scientists by definition they
evolve positions according to changing
facts and we saw in the pandemic that
originally the perceived scientific
wisdom was that masks for example would
be ineffective in preventing the spread
of covid then they changed their mind
about that we were told that the
vaccines would stop
passing on the virus and it turned out
that wasn't true we were told there's
been old debate as you know about where
the virus may have started the belief
was from a wet Market maybe it was from
this lab in Wuhan and so on
those who were anti-science
they leap on these things and they said
well there you go there you go why
should we believe or follow the science
when they do such dramatic u-turns in a
Health crisis for example what do you
say to that well it's true I mean
science actually does change its mind
because when I mean I think it was John
Maynard Kane said when the facts change
I change my mind what do you do sir yes
um and so this was this all happened in
such a hurry it was all
great rush to to produce advice and
there wasn't time to take the normal
balanced look at the evidence and so
naturally
they changed their mind
and it's a virtue of science actually
that they can change their mind
scientists can change them what is not a
virtue is that social media
allows
large groups of people to whip each up
each other up into a sort of lava yes of
self-righteous certainty yes positions
which can actually in a pandemic for
example be deadly to people I quite
agree I mean if the wrong types of
people who are most vulnerable to say a
covid virus if they believe this stuff
and don't for example get what was
pretty extensively seemed to be a pretty
safe vaccine in most cases could kill
them yes what do you think about that
new phenomenon in society social media
creating these kind of it is interesting
it interests me a lot actually because
there was a time when
um you could express your opinion by
writing a letter to the newspaper yeah
chances that would be not accepted by
theater but that was it that was the
only way you could communicate anybody
can do it and so and so it is actually
um possible for the sort of people who
write
graffiti on walls to reach the world if
if they Jack if they get the do you like
social media
no uh I don't on the whole I use it I
use them but I I don't I don't like them
why
because
there's a there's a culture of nastiness
there's a culture of hostility a culture
of
um outright rudeness which and is that
has that always been there and we're
just seeing it manifest itself now
because of social media or do you think
the very nature of social media whips
people up into be something that they're
not normally I I think you wouldn't
normally actually yell insults to
somebody's face if you've met them in
the street and that's in effect what's
going on
um it's partly fostered by anonymity
many people
don't use their own name on social media
and so they they call themselves Tinky
Winky or something and and therefore
they
feel they can yell abuse at people
without it rebounding on them is it more
important than ever that leaders
particularly political leaders of
countries
that they Pride themselves on veracity
of their public statements and is it
really dangerous when you have social
media this kind of tribal nature of the
following that if you have people who
literally don't tell the truth but have
huge positions of influence that can be
for a society very fracturing yes I
think so and I I think you're perfectly
right to focus on tribalism it's it's
been actually demonstrated that many of
us
believe what our tribe what's good for
our tribe that's the left-wing tribe or
the right-wing tribe
um rather than looking at the evidence
and I think we need to train ourselves
to get out of the tribal mindset and to
look at the evidence as it is I mean
we've seen it with brexit we've seen it
with Donald Trump we've seen it with
covid we've seen it just recently in the
UK with Gary lineker and this huge row
about him where his supporters
and I've been one of them even though I
didn't agree with what he said his
supporters have said this is about free
speech
those on the right in the sort of
conservative tribes have all immediately
said it's all about free speech he
should be fired for what he said and yet
you know that they would all be saying
the opposite
if it suited their tribe and we saw that
with say Jeremy Clarkson where all the
people paying for lineker's blood
defended Clarkson against demands for
him to be fired and similarly all those
defending Gary lineker who's on the left
and is considered a woke darling they
all wanted Clarkson fired so I looked at
these two stories and I thought well
actually I want them both to have the
right to say what they want to say and
be judged accordingly but they shouldn't
lose their jobs for honestly held
opinions however crass and offensive
they may be I agree
that's right I do yes I do I think I
think that
um
we too readily fall into the tribal
mindset of of right versus left and I I
rather admire Christopher Hitchens
latest virgins who was on the left and
of the right as well and you couldn't
Place him and and I was edited through
the Daily Mirror when we opposed the
Iraq War for example yes and we opposed
it very aggressively for several years
but I employed Christopher Hitchens in
that period because he supported the
Iraq War and that was a surprising
position for many people who supported
Christopher Hedges why is he doing this
and actually he argued his case with
great Verve and intellectual rigor as
you'd expect I didn't agree with him but
he argued it well
I once said if you're invited to debate
against Christopher Hitchens decline
all right professor Professor Stephen
Hawking told me shortly before he died
that the biggest threat to mankind was
artificial intelligence learning how to
self-design I'll play you that clip
after the break and get your reaction
still more from Richard Waters up
[Music]
Richard Dawkins is still with me so
Richard I had the great honor of doing
one of the last interviews with
Professor Stephen Hawking before he died
up at his office in Cambridge and I
asked him what I think is a pretty
important question let's take a look
is artificial intelligence
going to be the end of us
and if it's not
how do we best work with it ever since
the start of the Industrial Revolution
there have been fears of mass
unemployment as machines replaced humans
there is a greater Danger from
artificial intelligence if we allow it
to become self-designing for then it can
improve itself rapidly and we may lose
control
what do you think of that
well I think that on a massage
unemployment is one of the problems but
I think that
in a way they might do a better job than
we do I mean yes I could imagine in a
thousand years time perhaps um there'd
be nothing but robots would look back on
a kind of dawn age when
there were that means no humans yes why
would you look forward to that I suppose
you don't care because you won't be here
and I think that's what we look forward
to it I think it's an interesting
possibility that the future of humanity
might lie in its artificial Creations
really I'm not saying stuff of a horror
film isn't it yes
um I think it's interesting isn't it I
just really look forward to it I mean
I'd be terrifying that that could happen
yes it is rather yes you think it's a
possibility
I haven't got a long way to go I mean he
talked about
um self-reproducing robots and that's a
key
um I think it was either Von Neumann or
Morgan's term I forget which who
postulated this idea I think it was a
fun Diamond of a self reproducing
machine that could actually evolve
um well
I think we probably are on the threshold
of a major
breakthrough in artificial intelligence
I'm not that impressed by the way with
the one that was talking about now
called the chat GPT yeah I had had a go
on that and
superficially impressive but then I
happen to mention
Helen spurway who was the wife of JBS
holder in the great um biologist and it
said later Helen spoa married Richard
Dawkins
[Laughter]
which she didn't presumably she did not
yes and many many major factual errors
of that sort yeah
um but in the early days reminds me a
little bit of when they used computers
to play chess against the grand Masters
and the grand Masters sent the computer
packing but then the computer got better
and better and better and now there's no
human being who can beat the best
computers that's right or even come
close yeah so you just you have to
assume that this chat thing AI chat is
going to get progressively better I
think the problem is playing chess is
one thing because it's a limited domain
and there have been other
um AIS that have worked on
colored bricks on the table you know put
the blue one on top of the red one and
then knock knock it over that it can do
that but a versatile AI
I'm in a sentient AI is really what I
think I'm talking about to know whether
it really is sent sentient but um
Turing proposed the mathematician Alan
Turing proposed of a test whether he
could actually be fooled by it and you
probably will be fooled by yes
um I suppose I'm committed to the view
that sentience must be since we I know
that we have it I know that I have it I
presume you have it
um I think I'm committed to the view as
a materialist it must be in principle
possible for a machine to be sentient
um
Hawking was on The View once that
happens it's all over for the human race
yes
I don't see this all over for the human
race
um it could be especially if it was
self-reproducing you yourself compared
Trump
to Hitler
I would hesitate to compare anybody to
Hitler well I think you said in a way
you said national pride is evil
consequences prefer pride in humanity
German Pride gave us Hitler American
Pride gave us Trump British Pride gave
us brexit if you must have pride be
proud that homo sapiens could produce a
Darwin Shakespeare Mandela Einstein
Beethoven yeah so the implication was
that Pride leads into dark place but
that's different from that I agree with
that I I stand by that but I don't stand
by comparing Trump to Hitler I mean
they're both liars is it always a
mistake to evoke Hitler and the Nazis
and that's literally you're talking
about people
pretty pretty nearly yes I mean it it
was such an outlier that that um I I
would hesitate to compare anybody to him
in a full sense I mean you can compare
him in one sense like Trump and Hitler
are both Mega Liars that's true enough
um but
I wouldn't go much further what are the
other dangers do you think facing
mankind
oh
well
um nationalism
um national pride
um of the kind that we saw with the
Nazis where they literally want to take
over the world yes and and um in a
smaller where we're seeing it to put in
um
obviously
um climate change is one we have to
worry about
artificial intelligence is perhaps not
another one
um
you said before that Islam or
fundamentalist Islam is one of the
greatest I think I think fundamentalist
Faith where you believe absolutely that
you're right without any evidence is a
major danger because that license is you
to do anything if you're really really
sincerely believe that you've got right
on your side because God told you then
really we sort of understand how the
Inquisition mind worked and how the
modern islamist mind but you're being
accused of being an islamophobe are you
or would you be taking the same view of
the Christians back in there well I'm
not an Islamic what I am what I'm a
phobic about is
um clitoridectomy of throwing gay people
off buildings
um Banning dancing and music and having
fun generally I'm phobic about all those
sorts of things but that's different
from being islamophobe Muslims are the
biggest victim of islamism yes they are
there's been a big debate about this
Isis bride shamima begum whether she
should be allowed to come back to this
country do you have a view about that
your oven I'll say I haven't studied it
enough well she was married to an Isis
fighter yeah I know she was a young but
she was 15 when she went out there yeah
the debate really is what she groomed to
be part of this terror group in Syria
and as such should we show mercy and
allow her back to this country yes I'm
not going to say about that are you
worried about me do you get threats
because of the positions you've taken on
some of these things
when you saw what happened to salmon
rush to you
didn't send a shot of three
are you saying no you don't want to talk
about it or yes
right I mean that's interesting in
itself because is it
there are areas which you would prefer
not to discuss
I should have said that before we
started yeah no medicine I'm I think
it's sad that you can't
I don't think anything should be off
limits in interviews with people like
you the whole point of the world's
smartest thinkers is we ought to better
have free and open debate I don't think
we do because people use murderous
retribution against Free Speech really
is what it amounts to right
well I'm passionately in favor of free
speech
should there ever be limits to free
speech Yes I mean incitement to violence
that's that's the normal answer and I
think it's a good reason but outside of
that people should be free to I think so
yes have you noticed at Oxford a change
in the mentality of the way they operate
I don't think really at Oxford no um I
hope not I don't think so
who's the smartest thinker you've met in
your life
um if you've had a moment you sat there
and go my God this guy is or this woman
is oh many many times yes um you've
forced me to mention someone I would say
Peter meadower Nobel prize winning
medical scientist
um and what was it about his mind that
you found so oh Big Island he well he he
was a brilliant scientist but also a
wonderful wit a wonderful writer a
wonderful
um immensely knowledgeable
um
hugely well read
what do you hope to achieve you're 82
now you're saying no son of slowing down
you have a new book flights are fancy
Defying Gravity by Design and evolution
all about flying um
you've written 17 books I think you told
me in one of the breaks and it's a lot
do you hope to keep writing books
discussing things I do have any great
unfulfilled ambition well I'm writing a
book at the moment what's it about it's
called the genetic Book of the Dead
and it's anyone know what it's about yes
okay
um well if you if you look at a
camouflaged animal like a lizard in the
desert it's got It's in environment
painted on its back it's got stones and
sound and things actually it's the
ancestral environment that's placed on
its back because it's natural selection
of its ancestors that did that and my
point is that that
is not just Skin Deep the whole of the
animal every single little tiny detail
of the animal in its interior of every
cell will be as precisely a record of
ancestral environment as the skin is so
the animal is a description of the world
in which its ancestors lived fascinating
I want to come back and ask you one
simple question what is the question
that you Richard Dawkins would like to
have answered
before you die answer up hold your hold
your answer okay
[Music]
welcome back to you please welcome left
Richard Dorking on a cliffhanger which
is
right what is the question you would
most like to get answered I think it is
uh is there extraterrestrial
intelligence I think I would like to be
visited by well I will never be visited
by actual bodies I think but visited by
radio waves
um from another star system do you
believe it exists yes
uh I'm not totally confident but but I I
if if I well Carl Sagan once said he
didn't know and so he was pressed to say
well what's your gut feeling and he said
well I try not to think with my gut
but uh yes I I think statistically the
odds must be that that there is
it might be quite rare let's say maybe
only a billion instances in the universe
and that's very rare indeed because the
number of possible planets is something
like 10 to 22.
um so a billion would be very rare So
Rare we might never
encounter it what else would you love to
know origin of life
um the origin of the universe
consciousness
um if I were a physicist I would want to
know
um how to unify quantum theory and
gravity but not a physicist so don't ask
me about it when you saw Professor
Stephen Hawking with his black hole
Discovery and so on it's like you're
envious when you see them pull off
things like that
suppose so yes I mean there's a thing
called physics Envy yes um and I I
sympathize with that
um yes I I but I I don't have the the
intellect for that kind I don't have the
mathematics to do to do that
um see what's interesting to me have you
spent some time with you never met you
before
you don't seem that like
provocative or Bingo you got it I'm not
right where does this reputation come
from I don't know but I see some of the
clips from earlier yeah of you in your
more fire brand yeah I get provoked and
people right people goad me like like a
bullfighter yeah but I'm you don't
actually come over that one no I'm a
very mild do you feel you get a bad rap
yes
but what's the real Richard Dawkins like
then well
um
I I suppose I'm polite and and um
interested and interesting and I like to
talk to people and hear what they have
to say are you just incurably logical
are you basically like a human Spock
from Star Trek I would like to say that
no I'm I'm quite emotional as well I
mean I love poetry and music
um and are you romantic person I suppose
I am yes can you be logical and romantic
Sparkle was found that really different
I think so yes I think you can because
isn't it illogical romance yes it is
um but I I can be moved to Tears by
musical poetry
do you have a political allegiance to a
party
well I voted lib Dem most of my life
um and someone say that's a weird
religion well I I don't feel very
strongly about it I mean I I don't I'm
not I'm not as I'm not a zealot
do some of your sort of logical thinking
and this may be one of the reasons you
get a controversial rap so I'm sticking
into what you said for example there's
outrage feminists over the years
and it's quite interesting because you
said for example date rape is bad
stranger rape at knife point is worse
mild pedophilia is bad violent
pedophilia is worse if you think that's
an endorsement of mild pedophilia go
away and learn how to think pure logic
right I understand the logical thinking
yes but I also understand why a feminist
would think what the hell are you
talking about rape is rape it doesn't
matter whether it's date rape or knife
Point Break yeah I mean I think that's
so illogical because it what it means is
that I mean I I had a friend who was
actually raped in in Africa three men
pounded on her in a dark in a dark house
and and two of them held her down while
they took turns to rape her
um now that seems to me to be a
different order of magnitude to
um a boyfriend who gets drunk and goes
too far and and it seems to me that it's
absolute nonsense to say that there's
just rape is rape is rape of course
there are it's like it's like saying
a pickpocket who steals a quid from you
pocket is like a bank robber who you
know that there are clearly degrees of
well in a way but I would counter and
say I could see your logical mind
thinking that but actually if you steal
a pound or a million pounds you're a
thief if you kill someone uh You're a
murderer it doesn't matter how you kill
it and if you're if you're a rapist you
are a rapist and I can understand why
feminists would say well hang on who are
you to decide which is more invasive to
a woman on a scale of violence she
actually went on my my next tweet was uh
strange stranger rape is is bad date
rape is worse if you think that's an
endorsement a stranger go go away and
sit and learn how to think the point was
go away and learn how to think if you
think that talking about one thing being
milder than the other is an endorsement
of the of the mild one of course it's
not no I don't think it's that but it's
more like you're drawing you're drawing
a kind of comparative scale for
something where a woman would say many
women would say that actually rape is
rape it doesn't actually matter how I
know they would let's let's go back to
the stealing a quid from from
robbing a bank you're surely not saying
that they should have the same jail
sentence because theft is theft is theft
no but they're always but they're all
they're all thieves yes but so what
they're all thieves the Paul you
wouldn't get the same jail sentence for
varying degrees of sexual assault good
exactly that's all I'm saying right but
a woman might say that they can be
equally as invasive and terrible for
someone's life I believe that yes that's
possible yes possible yeah your logical
mind would allow that thought process
yes and and all I said was if you think
that's an endorsement of the mild one go
away and learn how to think
have we lost the ability to
think logically and critically about
things
some people may have would you sense we
have that everyone's quick to pounce on
these kind of things and say I'm
outraged I think so but I haven't really
thought through what they're outrageous
let me take one of the other ones you
even mentioned mild pedophilia that I
got I got hell for that yeah
um I was the victim of mild pedophilia
at school I expect you were many many
people were I wasn't no no I'm glad to
hear it
um you were yes now um suppose I had
said
this has ruined my life like this it's a
total catastrophe then somebody who
really was raped
by a priest say or by a uncle or
something night after night after night
he would say how dare you compare your
15 minutes of
embarrassment to what I went through
night after night after night that's
what I was saying
you get it I get your argument I'm not
entirely sure I completely concur with
it because I think what you're again
you're trying to do is individuals are
individuals they all react to things in
different ways I could imagine there'll
be some people who've been through what
you went through who would be scarred
for life by it's a different type of
personality you clearly so you're not
okay
um
I mean many I'd say most of my friends
at that school were brilliant and and we
just joked about it because you were
applesauce right no God no oh that's a
Catholic School which one were you at
well that's not relevant because because
that it it it's I don't I don't want to
mention it right have you talked about
this before
I think so yes yes it's no secret and
it's it's not a big deal it's in my
autobiography not a big deal but I mean
it's in my autobiography yeah
yeah I mean I it's interesting because
I can have really conversations like
this with people all day long and I
wouldn't be outraged by stuff I hear I'd
want to argue and Challenge and get to
the bottom of what you're really
thinking but we don't live in that kind
of world anymore people live in some by
alley yeah they do they just want to
pick out a line and then being sensed by
it yes and we've also got a culture of
just general victimhood I think in
society people want to be a victim they
want to play a victim they want to play
that victimhood card because they think
it's something that now gets celebrated
and can be rewarding actually for some
people I think that's true that's
different to how Society used to be I
think that's true yes is it I'll be
going the wrong way
well if you're right yes do you think
I'm right I think you probably are you
know who Dr Spock is right yes I do he
was Mr logical yeah I know yes do you
don't think you're the human
manifestation of him no what's the one
thing you'd like to achieve no rest in
the rest of your life well
um I think I'd like to be
um known for
science and for helping people to
understand science from understanding
science myself and not known for being
vehement and an atheist which is only
two of my books
you finally you've got a chance to write
your own headstone
here lies Richard Dawkins
he
um
I think I'd maybe copy Jacques mono the
great biologist i s he said I come from
I I seek to understand
well I started to understand I think I
understand you a lot better after
meeting you Richard thank you very much
indeed thank you enjoyed it very much
that's it for me whatever up to Keep It
Uncensored and like Richard Dawkins keep
asking questions
that's it good night
[Music]